that's why i really wanted this to be
honest and actually on that point if
you've stayed long enough to this part
of the video i'm going to reward you
with this story that i was not planning
on sharing hello everybody my name is
nayan i'm the black female engineer i
provide content for new and inspiring
software engineers and today we're going
into my one month reflection of working
at dreamworks so i started working at
dreamworks animation studios uh yeah
about a solid month ago i'm working on
the production engineering team
basically they provide products and
tools to be used internally so it
doesn't really go outside to y'all but
they help with the movie development and
animations and whatnot of the
company so i've been working there a
couple of weeks now so definitely not a
long time at all and so really this
reflection is going to be more first
impressions just how these first few
weeks have been and if you follow me on
instagram you may know what's coming um
if you don't follow me at the black
female engineer but yes it's been a lot
of ups and downs and so i'm going to go
through this category by category so i'm
not just spilling my guts everywhere and
so first i'll start with first
impressions of the team the team
demographically is definitely better
than the team i worked on before this
the team i worked on before this it was
i was the only woman on the team and i
was the only
black person in general and so with this
team it's about eight of us now that i
think i've never really
sat and counted the squares on the zoom
call but it's about eight of us and
three are women including me
yes including me there's three women and
yeah that's really
all there is to it in terms of age group
the men are definitely more experienced
and
the women the women
are including me more not new new but
just a couple of years in from what it
looks like so there is age diversity
which is good in any team and when it
comes to ethnic diversity that's when to
be honest it gets harder
for me
to
analyze because it's not very
i was gonna say it's not very black and
white
but no it's not very clear cut there's
no clear
way to tell really but from
my inference it's kind of the same makes
mix of like
three of the eight maybe four of they so
maybe 40 to 50 percent being ethnically
uh different than
the caucasian ethnicity everyone seems
chill to if chill means that you just do
your job
and go home
if that makes sense like no one is going
to pester you about something no one's
going to breathe down your neck about
something they're not you know high
maintenance like everyone's like hey
like this is the job and
clocking clock out goodbye and so i do
like that personally because i don't
really like the
mentality of this work is my life and
this work is all i do ever and i am my
work and so i'm not a fan of those kinds
of
auras and vibes uh whether that those be
the company-wide vibes i'm sure a few of
us can think of
companies known for that type of
mentality like we are family like no no
you're not and so i do like that
that seems to be the consensus of like
yeah get in do your job get out goodbye
and maybe i'll see you again tomorrow
maybe i won't because i'm gonna call in
and it'll be fine because no one really
cares about that thing here and so
that's actually been really cool to see
like people just say like yeah i'm gonna
be out tomorrow i didn't sleep well
so
sorry so i do kind of like that i think
that also comes with being salaried
being just like hey well i have my work
done so i'm gonna be at the beach and i
think that's great personally like we do
your work i don't see why
you should sit here for six more hours
so no i i do think that the team is very
cheap now going into the work i'm going
to talk more about this in a later video
but
basically yeah my team builds apps and
products to be used by other animators
and you know studio production and
whatnot and so
that's
that's really the extent of it it'll
never go out into the world some of the
apps they build are web apps some of the
apps are way more complex than that i'm
trying my best to just
learn what they build what each
app's purpose is what their apis look
like and just figure
just get more acquainted with everything
i think that's just going to be the
theme of this video like i'm just trying
to
get more acquainted and to learn as much
as i can and so yeah i've been working
for about four weeks now and last week
was my highest slash like only coding
week to kind of give you an idea of
the speed in which i'm integrating onto
this team i don't know if that's super
fast i don't know if that's super slow
for me i
i'm kind of anxious about it because i'm
like oh my gosh like come on i feel like
i'm not doing anything i'm not
contributing because i don't know i feel
like those of you have been on this
channel for a while know
or can kind of sense that that's who i
am like hey like let's do this like what
can i do to help let me be you know
useful let me
earn the money you're paying me and
whatnot and so that's definitely been a
huge point of anxiety for me and so yeah
last week was the first week i really
coded but that being said it wasn't code
for
was the word it wasn't code for
enhancing an app or anything it was more
like data analysis so it was more data
analysis type coding so i've been coding
in python i've never used python before
but that's what uh my team
that's one of the languages my team uses
they use python they use c plus they use
a little bit of java and so yeah i've
been learning trying to learn python and
i was using python to complete this task
i had not because i needed python to
complete it because i could have just
completed it via an excel document
but
python can help with it you know what i
mean it can help filter things it can
help find things it can help saying okay
so for this set of data only give me
these specific data points and so that's
what i mean when i say i wasn't actually
enhancing anything any one of their
products i was really just
on a task of like hey audit these things
and so i'm like okay cool and i just
pulled up vs code it was auditing via vs
code looking at what my terminal ran
back what my code ran back and using
that to fill out the deliverables i'm
set to give at the end of the assignment
i'm glad i took the coding off because
it forces me to learn that much more and
faster especially in a low risk
environment where it's not a product i'm
trying to enhance and so if i mess up
some code it'll just be like oh i messed
up let me actually instead use this to
get the right thing and it's not like a
big production failure or something i
hope what i'm saying makes sense because
while i'm talking i'm like ah maybe it
doesn't but yes that's what i was doing
this last week
another point i i feel like i should
have said this earlier so i have
been having a lot of anxiety
like i said
at work
part of it i don't think has helped by
me not really having
the support that is uh what's the word
the support that's expected my second
week there my manager left
to get married you know freaking selfish
so yes he loved to get married has been
gone for two weeks and so did my
appointed
mentor slash buddy on the team who's
also one of the women on the team she
left as well to go visit her parents
also
selfish again i don't know what these
people are doing and so
yes that's been my situation where i've
really just been like
where am i i don't know who to ask
especially because okay that's also been
hard because
everyone on the team kind of has their
own
thing their own product their own
assignments they don't it's not a team
where everyone is working together on
the same product it's and that's really
how it was on in my last job here it's
really like every one person has like
their own app their own product xyz yes
there's some collaboration here and
there when you need help and whatnot but
really it's like one person owns
something and so that's been hard
knowing who to go to because i'm like oh
okay well i need help with this but
okay let me look up the roster and
figure out who owns this thing and
whatnot and so that's made things hard
and with my manager being gone
also not knowing who
to ask
for who
is what like has this been a lot of
gray areas and so that definitely has
contributed to my anxiety because my
manager is actually coming back
for from day i'm filming on sunday you
will watch this either tuesday or friday
i'm not sure we'll see but you'll watch
this either too the following tuesday or
friday today is sunday and my manager is
coming back tomorrow mo monday for me so
by the time you watch this my manager's
back
and
i am so stressed out because i'm like
he's gonna come back and i have nothing
to show
i have nothing to show for his week's
gone and so i'm really fighting the urge
to
not work right now so that my task is
complete because
what i was working on all of last week i
was hoping to be done by friday but
there's so many data points there's
millions of millions like
tons of data points and again if you
follow me on instagram you know that
that was a big thing um for me one of
these days where i'm like
ah there's so much data points i had
said
on my instagram that was like 500 000.
no that that was 500 000 for one
like thing for one project i was going
through and it turns out that was like
the smallest project it looks like all
the other projects have millions of data
points and so you if you saw my computer
struggling that day like that's where
i've been and so
i have the
you know
code and program that i've written to
swift through this data points and give
me the information i need but it's just
taking forever where friday i just sat
there just
and running like four terminals running
the background trying to do four
different programs and i know that
doesn't help things go quicker but i was
just like i i
strategically did it where it wouldn't
be the slowest but it also wasn't the
fastest i was just trying to
finish before my manager gets here and
of course that didn't happen i have
about two more projects i need to run
data through but i was just like ah my
gosh so i'm really finding the urge to
not work right now and just run and not
even it wouldn't even be working here i
am justifying me working on a sunday but
i wouldn't really be working i just need
to run the terminal in the background
for the next like six hours because yeah
it took like
eight hours for me to go through about
two projects on friday and so and i only
have two left so
i'm fighting that urge
anyway i kind of went through a rabbit
hole there but anyway that has yes
contributed to a lot of
flusteredness that you can i'm sure see
here and what not but you know brighter
days ahead so overall what i've been
doing what i plan to continue doing for
at least the next two months is just
asking to shadow people
doing their job like i literally don't
care if it directly relates to what i'm
doing i just need to understand better
how you go through these tickets what
you look at when you go through these
tickets when i say tickets i mean
when we get assigned something so hey
you have to fix this bug or you need to
enhance this program and whatnot those
requests come through the form of
tickets we use jira and so those handle
slash house all of the tickets we have
and each different team members
assignments and so when i say ticket i
really mean assignment and so yeah
seeing how other people go through those
tickets of okay so the first thing you
look at is this and then the next thing
you look at is this and then this is how
you iterate through your process and
whatnot because i've seen that even if
it doesn't have anything to do with your
current project it's still helpful to
understand what type of mentality you
should employ what type of work process
you should have because i'm brand new
you know like i just picked up coding a
year ago and so i'm still brand spanking
you and i'm still getting a hang of just
that coding process when it comes to a
work environment and so just seeing that
is very helpful and so i've been doing
that trying to see like hey do you have
time i you know would love to just sit
with you and just be a fly on the wall
to share your screen and i'll certainly
just sit here i'll just be writing in my
notebook writing on my whiteboard and
that's it and i just watch you and with
being you that that's one thing i'll say
for any of y'all who are about to be new
or new currently or just started a job
take
advantage of that
people expect should expect you to know
nothing when you start on a job and so
do you know the saying like oh like no
question is a dumb question we all know
that's a lie i i to me i always feel
like that's a lie like i feel like there
are dumb questions and i will be judged
by
asking certain questions
but when you're brand new one month two
months three months in
ask every question they don't truly know
what you should know and so to them no
question really is dumb because they
don't know if you should know it or not
because your brand's picking you and so
take advantage of that and just say like
hey i just want to watch you or hey
what's x y and z bother the crap out of
them because if they go back to your
supervisors or your managers or your
product directors or whatever saying oh
yeah like she asked too many questions
like
that's not gonna go anywhere you know
what i mean and so and one they wouldn't
do that but two even if they did that
wouldn't go anywhere they would turn out
looking like
so
basically that's what i'm saying maybe i
shouldn't say that because i'm about to
be monetized in like a couple
of days anyway anyway just take
advantage of that newness like crazy and
bother every single body because at the
end of the day i'm trying to make sure
that you know i survive another day and
if you're annoyed by my questions
honestly i'd rather you be annoyed by my
questions than me not have a job so yes
that's
where i am right now if you see the
flustered nature of this video know that
it's a thousand times worse for me
in person and i'm not saying that to
scare anybody
anyone who knows me on a personal level
knows that i can really drive myself
into a hole by the anxiety i put on
myself and so it's been like my mom and
friends being like girl like they expect
you to be new chill out
calm down like you're doing the best you
can and they know that and they see that
so just calm down they expect you to
know nothing so give them what they want
no nothing for now and then later you
will slowly continue to grow i just
really wanted this to be honest i didn't
want to talk about flowers and rainbows
and sunshine especially because i don't
know i feel like
sometimes doing that aids in more harm
than it does in benefiting people
because then you watching this
and if you're in a situation where
you're new and you're struggling and i'm
over here like i'm doing great i have
built three apps and i'm actually going
to be an animator for one of the movies
and theaters out tomorrow like that
doesn't help
you because now you feel like you are
the problem when that is not the case
and so that's why i really wanted this
to be honest and actually on that point
if you've stayed long enough to this
part of the video i'm going to reward
you with this story that i was not
planning on sharing so
about a week
and a half ish ago
i
like my program manager set up a meeting
with like all of us newbies and so we're
on the call and yeah everyone's like
yeah like how's everyone we're all on
different teams so we're not all on the
same team but we're all on different
teams only in different locations
different x y and z but it's like yeah
how's everyone doing and their new roles
x y and z
and i
you know i'm just like scoping it out
like how honest can i be here and so
i'm just scoping it out and
everyone was like wow i'm doing amazing
i have coded 300 lines of code i just
you know put up these commits and i'm
doing x y and z and so they get to me
and i don't say like oh my gosh i'm so
stressed out and anxious and like x y
and z but i was just like oh yeah i'm
just
trying to learn you know um
it's it's coming it's coming along
um
hopefully i tell you i can tell you more
next week
and so
that happened
the call ends and i'm sitting at my desk
literally
about to burst into tears about to just
burst into tears because i felt like
that of like oh my gosh so
i'm the only one having trouble with
this i'm the only one having struggles
with learning and
transitioning into this new team and so
i like sat there especially head down
and just had to physically suck my tears
back in so i was like no like we are not
doing this we are not crying like naya
you should be in this growth learn
mindset and so no don't be hard on
yourself and statue
just
throw the tears back into my eyeballs
and not let them hit the floor
um
but yeah i just wanted to share that in
case you are in that situation or you
find yourself in that situation and it
just i wanted to share it to further
show how
harmful
telling why i'm not telling i'm not
saying those people were lying but how
harmful if they were lying or they were
over exaggerating their productivity and
whatnot how harmful it can be for
the people
i.e me around them and so that's another
reason why i just want this to be
extremely honest i am
very much in this anxious space very
much stressed out about
if i'm doing enough right now and it
is a really big point of
struggle for me right now and i'm really
hoping that as the weeks and months go
on i
can
calm myself down and i think in general
i just need to learn to calm myself down
no matter what because to be honest even
if i'm six months a year in i can't
imagine
a time where i'm not stressing myself
out about not being fast enough with a
ticket or
asking too many questions or xyz i truly
can't imagine
myself not being stressed out
and anxiety-written about those things
and so to me the problem is more
focused on my mindset on those things
rather than
the situation at hand if that makes
sense i'm not
i think i need to instead work on
bettering my mentality when it comes to
working in general when it comes to
being on a team in general when it comes
to coding in general just being better
with my mentality and being kinder to
myself in general that's all i say about
that i hope this video is not 30 000
minutes long if it is well
that's
what we'll have to do with it and i hope
in general you all got something out of
this
and enjoyed it somehow i hope it wasn't
too depressing or anything but yeah i
hope you all enjoyed this and i will see
you all later please like and subscribe
but thank you thank you bye